- [Joshua] Garden City is, it's an oasis.
I hope it's what America becomes.
- [Miguel] You'll find
a lot of people here
that are willing to do hard work.
They'll come in and
they'll sit down, unwind.
Anyone can get their hair cut
here at Exclusive Barber shop
but only the best can work here.
- [Announcer] To see a glimpse
into the future of America,
Modelo looks not to its
coast, but to its heart.
It's there that we found
the hard-working community of Garden City,
a place where people come
together to make a better life.
- Of the barbershops today,
are missing a whole lot
of what it used to be,
where there was guys would come in,
they socially connect.
- The whole community comes in here,
and they all get along.
- [Joshua] Younger guys
listen to older guys,
and older guys listen to younger guys.
Ideas are exchanged, conversations happen.
I mean that's what happens in here,
and everybody seems to enjoy that.
- It's just real fun to be here really.
- I mean there's so many different people
that come in here,
it's always interesting.
It's always a conversation
from somebody from somewhere else.
I really enjoy that part.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Carlos] Every time I get a chance to,
I'm in the studio trying to do something.
Make a noise.
What I'm trying to work at
is get my name out there.
I want the world to know my music,
where I came from, my culture.
- [James] You can trust each
other when you know each other.
If you wanna know about Garden City,
you read the newspaper.
When you read the newspaper,
you see my stories.
I'm willing to work past the 9-to-5,
if I have to, to cover these stories,
because it's important
to me and the community.
- People working together
here in Garden City,
the spirit comes from
just trust and respect.
- People from all over the world
have kind of unified together
to form a really nice town.
I believe we all want
our children to grow up
better than what we did,
and the best way for that is to
live peacefully amongst each other.
I mean that's, that's what I
think we could learn from it.